[Music]
in order to be irreplaceable one must
always be different
don't spend time beating on a wall
hoping to transform it into a door
[Music]
there are people who have money
and people who are rich
[Music]
the most courageous act
is still to think for yourself
aloud
[Music]
adornment what a science beauty what a
weapon
modesty what elegance
[Music]
fashion is not simply a matter of
clothes
fashion is in the air
born upon the wind one intuits it
it is in the sky and on the road
[Music]
a girl should be two things
classy and fabulous
[Music]
i only drink champagne on two occasions
when i'm in love and when i'm not
[Music]
the best things in life are free
the second best are very very expensive
[Music]
a woman who doesn't wear perfume has no
future
[Music]
where should one wear perfume a young
woman asked
wherever one wants to be kissed
[Music]
dress shabbily and they remember the
dress
dress impeccably and they remember the
woman
a woman has the age she deserves
[Music]
you can be gorgeous at 30 charming at 40
and irresistible for the rest of your
life
a woman who cuts her hair is about to
change her life
a woman can be overdressed but never
over elegant
a woman with good shoes is never ugly
elegance does not consist in putting on
a new dress
i don't know why women want any of the
things men have
when one of the things that women have
is men
if you're sad add more lipstick and
attack
[Music]
fashion changes but style endures
the best color in the whole world is the
one that looks good on you
women think of all colors except the
absence of color
i have said that black has it all white
too
their beauty is absolute
it is the perfect harmony
fashion has two purposes comfort and
love
beauty comes when fashion succeeds
elegance is when the inside is as
beautiful as the outside
some people think luxury is the opposite
of poverty
it is not
it is the opposite of vulgarity
[Music]
simplicity is the keynote of all true
elegance
[Music]
i don't do fashion
i am fashion
[Music]
dress like you are going to meet your
worst enemy today
fashion that does not reach the streets
is not fashion
[Music]
my life didn't please me so i created my
life
[Music]
elegance is not the prerogative of those
who have just escaped from adolescence
but of those who have already taken
possession of their future
i don't care what you think of me
i don't think of you at all
[Music]
success is achieved by those who don't
know that failure is inevitable
you live but once you might as well be
amusing
gentleness doesn't get work done unless
you happen to be a hen laying eggs
hard times arouse an instinctive desire
for authenticity
[Music]
how many cares one loses when one
decides not to be something but to be
someone
there is no time for cut and dried
monotony
there is time for work
and time for love
that leaves no other time
if you were born without wings do
nothing to prevent them from growing
nature gives you the face you have a
twenty life shapes the face you have at
30
but at 50 you get the face you deserve
youth is something very new
20 years ago no one mentioned it
since everything is in our heads we had
better not lose them
as long as you know men are like
children
you know everything
i am not young but i feel young
the day i feel old i will go to bed and
stay there
gem la vie i feel that to live is a
wonderful thing
one shouldn't spend all of one's time
dressing all one needs are two or three
suits as long as they and everything to
go with them are perfect
fashion is made to become unfashionable
it's always better to be slightly
underdressed
luxury must be comfortable
otherwise it is not luxury
[Music]
fashion is architecture
it is a matter of proportions
a girl should be two things
who and what she wants
[Music]
men always remember a woman who has
caused them concern and uneasiness
only those with no memory insist on
their originality
if a man talks bad about all women it
usually means he was burned by one woman
[Music]
i wanted to give a woman comfortable
clothes that would flow with her body
a woman is closest to being naked when
she is well dressed
i've done my best in regard to people
and to life without precepts but with a
taste for justice
[Music]
you